alright we are live okay we are back
again with gen officially number three
All Right see how how it's been going to
spend two weeks yeah oh I know the last
one you were kind of uh getting back in
the swing of things after all the new
year holiday stuff so hard ones going
what's up good big I've been super busy
which has been good I've been writing
lots of copy for Mike new client as well
as you and a few others and um right
what what who's your new client um oh so
bold is um is the name of her sight oh
so bold calm and I finished it in
charity has a live in her sight it's a
great 000 h yeah oh h sob 0 LD calm ok
cool yeah yeah it's very cool yes I'm
excited about it's good for her cuz she
launched the site when she wanted to and
so that's really cool too she's an
entrepreneur over in maryland on the
east coast so um yeah really cool so
yeah we keepin busy monitoring pardon
how did you find her she found me she's
the one I was talking about that was the
first person who who I work with it i
didn't get some kind of referral from
just found my website very cool ok yeah
I don't know she she said she'd get a
google search and she couldn't member
exactly the keyword but somehow came
across me and sell you know it was just
meant to be yeah i like it i want to
pull up her sight to see this copper
that you wrote hold on the sua screen
sure yeah
there we go okay oh so bolcom yeah it's
a free promotion here yeah it's great
you plus heart oh come on website there
we go you plus heart what does it say
equals bold living alright cool yeah so
what did you write you wrote this whole
home page copy for her you stop with the
home page copy for her and then if you
get her her about page um actually all
this so the start here copy the about
page actually I didn't seem to start
here she must have just put that live oh
cool ya know any about page and the
contact page I'll all three all four of
those pages being oh so bold is about
standing still interesting ok so ya know
target consumer is someone who is super
busy um like mom entrepreneur okay so
yeah cool very cool okay yeah what else
and then um I've been working on um
doing more a twitter updates about
fantasy so I did a couple of week I was
all like ambitious scoop because I was
like I wanna do what a day and I didn't
I did like two a week that's great I I
was happy but I did sir and I did a
couple like you suggested not just
quoting other people but a couple of my
own so that's kind of cool house there
has it been responsive any others okay
I've got a couple of retweets not as
much as I you know doc that's okay
that's all right which one is getting
more your own personal stuff for the
sharing other people's stuff share into
people's so far yes so far yeah what
about what about you is do you get more
response when you quote other
entrepreneurs sir ah its a mix its a mix
the ones that I tend to get the best
results are are are the spur of the
moment ones okay nah I'm upset about
something or I'm really excited about
something and and in that moment I I
send out a tweet or update on facebook
and not that's what gay
the most of all of them all right cuz
you're like emotional and involved right
yeah yeah I won't see that should be
right up your alley right exactly I mean
look to the video about this recently
right or something you or it was maybe
when your newsletters talked about that
ah maybe yeah yeah probably yeah it's
hard to keep up its hard to keep up with
all the videos um yeah those tend to do
the best I still will schedule other
ones with things that have inspired me
in the past or might take a copy from my
newsletter because I I spent a lot of
time writing my newsletter and so I
might take some lines from that and
schedule that out over the next week so
the more powerful lines right and those
are hidden miss some of them do really
well some of them don't um and same with
the famous stuff you know I don't care
so much about the response I'm doing it
because I think it's a good message to
share sure and don't just pay attention
to oh this one got 20 comments so I'm
gonna do more like this um but yeah the
ones where I'm really emotionally
invested are the ones that tend to do
the best right that makes sense totally
makes sense to me ruger that's right
that's right okay thank ya and then I've
been working on my video a little bit i
have new respect for you at all those
videos you do have a week oh my gosh I
can't believe how many you do every week
so um so yeah I've worked on that and
that was awesome was a good experience
so what's the video on pardon this is
the video for for the aspirational
company true exactly yeah and how's that
going what's the latest it's good it's
done I just my daughter helped me finish
editing last night because she's a whiz
on iMovie and so she helped me out so
it's done so i think i'm gonna send it
off to i'm a look up the contact there
at room company and set it off to them
it's going along so I have to like put
up maybe post it somewhere and have a
link to it yeah but this isn't just for
them though it's for everybody right
like posted on YouTube yeah yeah okay
good do you have a channel I don't
okay no still have to get one another
assignment get that name locked up yeah
yeah are you happy with the video I am
yeah so what happens in the video what
are you doing so I did what you
suggested um I could show to you if you
want sure I don't know how to do the
share let's see here on the left side ok
green arrow on top of a computer screen
okay here we go yeah hi let's see if
this works uh okay let's try this James
you to prove you okay you're good did it
have a stark screen share button right I
see a screen okay all right here we go I
press play no yeah hi I'm John I'm a
fantasy copywriter at you so much calm
and I use came to see my copy to tap
into people's dreams and desires and I
believe that the first step to making
your fantasies come true is to write
them down because we're to make it real
so I thought it would be really fun to
show you how i use fantasy in my copy by
picking an aspirational client someone I
really want to work with and write some
copy for them and then show you the
before and then the after with the
fantasy so you can see the difference
and you can also see the process that i
go through so you can maybe apply it to
your own business whether you're writing
some copy for a website page or maybe a
product description or even in your
advertising and marketing messages so
the company that i chose is called true
and company and i just love these guys
they're an online lingerie company and i
just found them a few months ago and
what you do is you go on to their
website and you answer a few questions
it only takes a couple minutes and then
what they do is they take that and they
make recommendations for you and then
you pick from the recommendations and
they mail them to you so you can try
them on at home in front of your own
mirror under your own clothes and make
sure it works and it fits and then you
go back on their website tell which ones
you want to keep and
but the ones you've done with the
postage that they provide and I just
found the whole experience to be really
great and I love their selection of
lingerie is fantastic so one of the
things that I found you go to their
website is just a gorgeous website
really great copy on their homepage when
you go to the individual product
descriptions I found that they could
really use an infusion of fantasy and
besides what better product can you
think of they have a fantasy with the
lingerie right so I'm here's when the
items that i bought from them it's
called across the universe and i just
bought this broad because i just thought
it was really unique and modern looking
it just it was really attractive bra and
so here's what they say on their website
about this bra you won't have to go far
across the universe to find this
essential charcoal gray push-up bra
beautiful stripe details cover soft
slightly padded cuffs to provide just
the right amount of lift a contrasting
mint green class adds a special touch to
your everyday ensemble underneath so
what my process is when I'm writing
fantasy copy is that I pull out words
that describe the product itself so in
this case I'd pick things like striped
and gray and ribbon because it has a
really cool ribbon looking strap and
then also things like space and stars
obviously take a little bit of the hinge
from the name across the universe and
then also uplifting because it's a
push-up bra and then the other thing
that I do is write down words about I
want to feel what I'm wearing the bra so
this case I chose things like radiant
and weightlessness and floating against
taking a little bit of a hint from the
name and space theme here floating
through space but also when you're
wearing to push abroad if you want to
fill a weightless up here and then I
also chose fullness as one of the words
so using some of those words and a few
others this is the copy that I came up
with for them like that roof to a party
last summer when the star light bouncing
off your skin seemed to light you from
within you weightlessly ribbons your way
through the space and I've lifted those
you touched with your hint of fullness
and intimate gaze this chuckle grand
push-up bra has beautiful stripe details
on soft slightly padded cups too
on a gradual lift that's out of this
world and a surprising make green class
that gleams like the moon against the
night sky so you can see there how I use
the words to describe the bra and how I
want to feel inside that fantasy copy so
here's another example this is the other
bra that I bought from them and I chose
this Bravo I mean it's obvious right
it's red it's lacy it's sexy and I just
thought it was a great looking raw and
it looked really comfortable and here's
what they said on their website about
that bra one of our best selling styles
the Coquette brought by montell is sexy
stylish and supportive this Oliver red
lace unlined underwire bra features
stretch soft cups with elasticized top
edge that conforms to your natural shape
the high side support panels keep
everything contained which makes this
bra highly recommended for fuller busts
so again using my process of describing
the bra I pulled out words obvious ones
like red stretch lace right but then I
also chose a few others like French
flirty romantic and again taking a
little bit of a hinge from the name
Coquette and then I also just read words
that I how about how I wanted to feel so
in this case I chose things like
supported and sexy and also carefree and
admired so using those words and again a
few others this is the copy that I wrote
enlighten your romantic notions of
flying to France flirting with the pilot
as you stretches his arm to support you
stepping off the jet in full admiration
of fellow travelers noticing your
carefree delicate style this sexy red
lace unlined underwire bra features
stretch soft cups with elasticized top
edge that conforms to keep you
comfortable on or off the runway the
high-flying side support panels keep
everything contained but never
restrained resulting in a perfect
landing for fuller busts so you can see
how using fantasy in your copy really
tells a story and makes it so much more
captivating and really an enjoyable
experience for your customers and in
essence what you're doing then is you're
making your product or service
help your customers fantasies come true
so I hope that you will also consider
writing down your own fantasies so that
they can come true too so if you want to
find out a little bit more about me or
my fantasy copy you can find me online
at you so much com thank you so much so
there you go I got a real good how does
it feel watching it it feels good yeah
it's so weird to see my face up close
like that cuz I saw it on the phone
before ok wasn't it just click on the
the green thing again ok there we go can
you see me yet ah not yet we still see
black screen ok let's try this again
there you go yay yeah that was really
good a member I mean the first videos of
me I hated them yeah molly was decent
but I watched like oh turn it off turn
it off but I want to watch myself you
know where our own harshest critic um
literally that was really really good
for for a first time video that's one of
the best that I've seen or like an
expert type of video that was really
good thank you yeah it was hard to watch
my like the close up but it's like the
lighting could have been better and all
that right so it's all good though it
was just like you said it was more for
practice and and you know hopefully to
maybe get a few clients to see how I
copy ya know I liked the I mean the
background look nice again they're not
expecting you to be a professional video
person you're you're writing copy um and
it was good it was it was yeah solid I
like the words coming on I like to
explain your process the sample of what
you bought uh yeah that was a great idea
you had free yeah i love i love seeing
that that really brings it home um now
it's like howdy
this into a series right yeah so it's so
it's ongoing and kind of figuring into
your process one just for the time right
like how much can you dedicate to this
it'll get faster you know this look like
how long did it take you to actually do
all that it you know actually observe
writing the copy was like really like
only a couple hours like you know but
the rest was what took me so long
because of course it takes a while to
try and figure out you know you know the
whole I think was more just a practicing
without saying um and uh you know just
make you know I had my copy points but
then it was funny because my daughter
was practicing with me and she was like
mom you're saying unto but you gotta get
to the point and I was laughing Christie
was like like things you would have said
I was kind of crack it up so anyway but
it was so it was more the practicing but
I think what you're right like the more
I do it the probably the easier will be
yeah I mean it used to take me like a
full week to do one video it was brutal
um and now ya can pop out 14 in a day
but that's like nine hundred videos
later right right exactly you're doing
like one every other week maybe and then
you know I can use that like you said as
a series and have you know send examples
to clients you know potential clients
yeah and it shows you off so well
because it's authentic you know if you
keep doing the same client you'll have
to find different ways to talk about it
so and I like the aspirational client
like I and I think that could be a
series so this is a one showing off a
product that you bought maybe the next
one could be like what's on their
homepage or what is under about page or
how do they tell their story and how
they got started or the contact page
like you can break down different
sections mm-hmm how you would add some
fantasy copy to it so it's it's the same
thing each time it'll start to get a
little boring yeah yeah um I like it
yeah I think people would subscribe to
that and learn something from it
is it the same process you go through
each time so you said you know you try
to find words that that you like and
relate to the product and then you weave
that in well specifically for a product
like that yeah I do go through that
process I go I find words and then it's
you know obviously it's a little bit
more involved than I put the video
because if somebody I would have taken
forever but you know I obviously use
those words than to compose a fantasy
story so I don't just like you know
stick words in there I like think of a
story that you know would play well into
into that particular product you know I
mean so I can both those cases you know
with the bras it was situations where
you be wearing that bra and you'd be
admired I need to be stepping off the
plane you know that kind of thing so
that was kind of my process it wasn't
just let's write a little story but
these words in there it was more about
what with that customer want to be you
know what would one of their fantasies
be so yeah I think the length of this
okay what it's like six minutes five and
a half minutes yeah it was yeah little
or five minutes yeah that's that's not
by like people will watch that it's not
bad um do you think it along I was
worried about that it was hard to like
it was hard to like write the copy and
show the before and after and not have
you know be a little long no no it was
good and you went to two products
I was thinking a little bit through it
that the intial could have been a little
bit tighter and getting to offer you a
little bit faster but not much like it
was it was still pretty good it was it
was really good it was really good um I
think what might help a little more for
future ones is is to have a quick even
like 10 seconds jizz on your process and
you kind of touch on it right but break
down a little more what you do and maybe
that even becomes a screen that you have
on each one so you did it okay but maybe
just a little bit more in depth on it to
say so here's what I do I look at I look
at the product i try to figure out a
story and it starts with picking out
some keywords like if you have your
three step process your five step
process right the goal is to showcase
you as an expert and it's educating its
educating the people who are watching
the video right so some of them will
never be clients of yours but they need
help with copywriting and they will
learn from you and be able to improve
their own business or their charity or
whatever it is and that you know there's
a lot of good in that too right and then
some of them will say I don't have the
time to do this I want to hire an expert
someone who's the best of what she does
I'm gonna hire her and they don't you
don't want to spend their time doing
something they're not really good at so
outline that process helps showcase your
expertise right that's kind of like tell
them what you're going to say before you
say it and so go through that that's
that like one where you're like you do
this already it's just maybe
articulating it into you know 35 how
many points you need to showcase here's
what I go through and really show off
that you know you know what you're
talking about right right that makes
sense yeah I did that um yeah and you
might even be able to do it if you're
worried about the time you could you
could cut it down to one product but
maybe go more in detail on the process
um you can flip back and forth to like
okay here's your step one you know I'm
gonna pick out keywords and so I picked
out red stripe whatever the things were
and then step 2 i'm gonna do whatever
i'm going to come up with a story so
like how did you how did you figure out
the flight with a pilot and write like
so you're kind of you're jumping all the
way to the end right right and that's
great but if you explain the process
more it really shows off your expertise
um and that's like a goal of this
video's to showcase you as knowing what
you're talking about okay yeah I was
worried about that cuz there was
actually quite a lengthy process that I
you know kind of skipped over because I
thought well this video would be so long
if I went to it too much but yeah I like
that idea maybe just doing a single
product in just a little bit more about
it yeah yeah and like six minutes even
seven minutes it's not I've done videos
that are longer that yet lots of use to
so as long as if information is good um
yeah but overall great like that those
are minor things that fix up that was a
really good first video and it's gonna
help people well sure what about let me
know I'll tweet it out awesome oh yeah
it's great okay um if you could do that
every other week that'd be fantastic
yeah I like that idea yeah and I could I
like the idea of picking different
businesses to and different kinds of
businesses because even though I'd go
through a similar process with like a
service company like if you think of
maybe somebody who's a fitness coach
obviously you're just you know you don't
describe the specific product but you
still go through sort of a similar
process would be different or like when
I'm doing an about page you don't have
some specific things that I do
specifically for about pages that i
don't do for other pages you know things
like that yeah and you can also break
down what you're doing for your clients
so you know here's what i did with oh so
bold and she is a
a coach who helps entrepreneur women get
started or whatever it is and go through
what her problem was and then explain
how you helped and it's also great
promotion for your client right yeah but
you sent your ears he's going to be
featured on more videos I mean ideally
you want to be able to make you know get
paid what you're worth and that comes
from working with typically bigger
clients so you don't want to only focus
on the little guys who may be your
current clients who aren't necessarily
paying you the big bucks mmhmm yeah
assumption i guess about what the budget
was to that project um mind your words
that you know bra company who has a
bigger team have bigger marketing budget
they can they can really think more so
you don't want to just pigeonhole on
your current clients but if you can mix
those two things up I'm balance great
yeah okay um what else do we have so how
is the domain name social-media handles
all that stuff well I finally changed my
social my twitter handle it so it's now
this is you so much this is this is you
so much it work now so um so that's cool
I'm excited about that this is the new
one this is you so much anyone right
yeah the other one was rock star jen
says what right yeah but I'm even
thinking about changing it again I know
it's terrible but because my official
business name I think is going to be
much and so this is much was available
so I I might do that I just I feel like
it's really good to really really
consistent with my website yeah this is
you so much so that's kind of why I
originally chose that and you so much as
taken you so much was taken yeah burger
if I some person who never tweets
unfortunately I detected I followed that
person hoping that they you know fall
back they don't they don't we don't
follow they don't do anything so just
say now they're dead burn yeah okay yeah
so uh yeah it is good to get consistent
and and you know what
short of the name it's easier to put
more characters yeah and also people
gonna retweet you then they can fit your
name and more easily oh yeah I didn't
think about that right hello yeah so
I'll do a lot of Twitter chats with
companies for trying to target
entrepreneurs and I'll write messages
and the whole idea is to get a dialogue
going and you want people writing to you
and sharing your stuff and I had in
comments so ideally your tweets are
short enough that they can add their own
little thing on top of it say like great
tweet and then retweet your name and
then your quote right okay got all fit
in there yeah exactly there's a Twitter
so um yeah but I mean that has to feel
right it's gotta represent you and I
mean shorter syllables easier to
remember mm-hmm so you might want to
just grab the name anyway just ya know
that you can get away Justin crazy yeah
totally yeah unfortunately just much by
itself is taken by a much music which I
hadn't heard of before I've been it's up
in Canada right like very much music is
a good friend here yeah what evan is
taken to so right but the co founder of
twitter his name is Evan so you so my
gosh so he took Evan there's like
there's no way I'm gonna get ever Evan
or anything so that's okay though i'm
good with Evan Carmichael yeah well it's
kind of your brand so yeah um okay what
else you were talking to local business
owners mm-hmm so yeah I've I started
writing a look copy for my clients who
has the Apothecary skin care and I'm
really excited for her cuz she just
found out that urban outfitters might
carry her product which is really cool
um so that would be great exposure for
me to UM and other than that you got
I've been keep you busy doing those
things go ahead that's good progress is
good progress um so I guess before the
next time we meet what that that video
is gonna go live you're gonna set
can a little be up you're gonna you're
going to message me and I'm going to I'm
going to tweet it out for you too all
right cool uh you're gonna figure out
what your twitter handle is gonna be and
you give a keep posting mm-hmm for the
next video you want to do your client or
do you want to do more in the
aspirational side no I can't like the
idea of doing my client if she's cool
with it yeah yeah usually usually
clients are oakley oh they love the free
publicity you're not gonna slam them and
say this website sucked and you know
like over the objectives and the
problems but but always put it in a good
light I know you'll be back yeah
absolutely yeah yeah and I also need to
update my um my homepage still with more
cut more fantasy copy so I'll put that
on my list to do this week too ah good i
like it yeah i really want to get that
doubt i actually want to do that before
today but I just I didn't have time that
video Evan come on why me you gotta
hustle here we go I know tell me about
it accident one of the things I was
thinking about asking you about was just
the whole time management thing you know
veena startup and having it another
full-time job it can be really tough I'm
sure you purchase from other people like
you know any any thoughts
recommendations for people people who
are like overwhelmed and and trying to
get together yeah you got a pic you
gotta pick the project that you really
want to work on you know it what's
what's what are you getting the most
value from and what feels right so it's
like the video was great it looked
really good for first video you're good
at it you may feel like wow that took so
long but it's going to be half as long
next time it's gonna keep getting better
is your first time like the first time I
do anything usually is not fantastic and
takes him forever right proud of that
alright and then I you know what I'd
also try to think at what point do you
leave that job to do your own thing full
time I count how much how much money do
you need from clients on a monthly basis
but what is what does that look like
that point because that's the goal right
it's leave your job and do you think
what is that
scenario you look like for you maybe you
really have it in your mind but knowing
that kind of helps you get through all
the crap right yeah almost not have
enough time and all that so when you
don't have some necessary share it here
with everybody watching but it's a good
it's a good goal to keep in mind for
your self to help you get you feel yeah
I agree you're right and I have done
I've sort of pencil to that I guess so
it definitely has been in you know on my
mind but feeling like it's more concrete
is important you're right so and
continuing to focus on that yeah all
right good luck all right Thank You Evan
thanks man five see you in a couple
weeks right